انتصف عمر سائد بين الحريه والاسر تحمل
اثنين وعشرين عاما ولم يتبقى الا القليل
وشهرين 14 يوم لحتى زائد ما يطلع نستناه
على احر من الجمر لكن تبدلت بهجه العد
التنازلي للايام اذا بدات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بتشريع قانون لسحب
مواطنه واقامه اسرى الداخل الفلسطيني
والقدس
وابعادهم لدى انتهاء محكومتهم عن القدس
ومناطق الثمانيه والاربعين صعب علينا انه
يطلع ملكي امي وابوي او على الاقل اروح
على قبرهم
هيك كانت فكره صعبه اننا نستوعبها اليوم
بيجيء قرار اصعب انه
ما تطلع على ارض على البيت اللي انولدت
فيه ما تطلع على اهلك وين لازم يستنوك
يستهدف القانون المدانيين بتهم تصنف
اسرائيليا اعمالا ارهابيه لكنه يستثني
سجناء يهودا مدانين بجرائم ارهاب ضد
الفلسطينيين وعندما سئل احد نواب الائتلاف
الحكومي عن ذلك اجاب نعم
يهودي حتى اذا كان قاتلا مجرما سفاحا لم
يفكر حتى في طرح امكانيه سحب جنسيته
مواطنته فقط عندما يكون همم عربي
ليقال انك مواطن مع وقف التنفيذ لكن
اشكاليه القانون لا تقتصر على الجانب
العنصري فحسب نتحدث عن قانون عنصر من
الدرجه الاولى القانون ايضا غير دستوري
وهو يتعارض مع مواثيق المواثيق الدوليه
التي تقر بانه لا يجوز سحب جنسيته اي فرد
في حال لم تتوفر جنسيه اخرى لدي اعلنت
الحكومه الجديده سلسله اجراءات ستتخذوا
للتضييق اكثر على الاسرى بعضها يفاقم
معاناتهم داخل السجن وبعضها الاخر يضيق
الخناقه عليهم حتى بعد انتهاء محكومتهام
كان تسجنهم خارج السجن وتبعدهم عن مدينتهم
الاحد
لا تكتفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
باحكام عاليه يقضيها الاسرى داخل سجون
الاحتلال ويراها الفلسطينيون جائرا ليضاف
اليها حكم اخر يعتبره الاسرى وعائلاتهم
الاصعب اذ يبداوا في اليوم الذي لطالما
انتظروه ولا موعد محددا
لانتهاء ايه
الجزيره من امام سجن عوفر العسكري شمال
القدس المحتله